and she said excuse me and I was like
man like I need to back up or leave like
well we can't do that for you so she
started charging at me I came all the
way back into my office into an enclosed
space and I hit her in the face a
shocking moment caught on camera when a
Target employee punches a customer in
the face after she cornered him in an
office
you backed him into an office and you
got hit in the face unfortunately when
people got backed into a corner they can
choose no no they can choose to do the
right thing or they can choose to lash
out okay you were in the wrong here just
so I held them she says the whole
altercation was her way to take a stand
this is my Rosa Parks moment dude
don't play with me the incident happened
on October 22nd of last year at a Target
in Blue Ash Ohio security video shows 37
year old Karen Ivory checking out at the
register when the bill surpasses one
thousand dollars Ivory says she won't
have enough
okay
I'm not going to have enough money to
pay for this I need to talk to the
manager if you happen to be walking by
Body camera video captures Target
manager Ashley Meyer describing to
police what happened so I I came around
and I was like hey what can I do for you
okay usually it's like like the price is
wrong or whatever
she starts going on this The Shield
about how like
I've had a privileged life and she's
been disadvantaged and then said that
she was asking Target to make
reparations for her
and I said that's not something we can
do tonight if like if you need a
donation like you can call tomorrow
okay and then she like she was like you
need to put me in touch with someone
tonight and I was like I can't there
isn't
okay like strange yeah and then she got
really close to me so I put my hands up
and backed up and she like followed me
she was like like breathing into my
eyeballs
yeah
so she got really close to me I put my
hands up I touched her shoulders because
she was like coming into my space okay
um and then she like because I touched
her she like anything
after that and just started screaming
really loudly and like back against the
soda machine okay and then that's when I
think
yeah he called she called our security
person security video shows the incident
unfold as Ivory approaches the manager
and gets in her face after that a loss
prevention manager approaches so what
happened
she told me that she wanted to wreck it
out and I told her we couldn't do that
okay and then she said excuse me and I
was like man like I need you back up or
leave like well we can't do that for you
so she started charging at me I came all
the way back into my office into an
enclosed space and I hit her in the face
surveillance video shows Ivory run after
the manager and into his office when she
approaches he punches her in the face
while the security video does not have
audio the manager later described the
incident to police on body camera video
I tried to
literally close her out but at that
point she was like pretty much running
so she barreled her way in and then Kate
kept coming into my office okay
considering the better like right in her
after the manager punches Ivory in the
face security video shows him calling
9-1-1 what did your notes say the lady
came in and punched her mat
yeah some sort of shenanigans didn't say
anything about managers that somebody
came into an office I thought it started
assaulting him
allegedly this chick's impaired when
officers arrive body camera footage
captures Ivory arguing with the manager
as officers work to get her information
I tried to close you out of my office
and you just kept on pushing your way in
that's right no sir I didn't push my way
in yes I can't no I came around the
corner quickly hey
no excuse you stop talking when I'm
telling you you stop talking okay
do you know who I am uh we'll figure
that out when I get your ID Ivory later
tells police officers the incident
stemmed from her request for reparations
on her purchase so what caused the
history on here today
[Music]
um
who are you going to have this big
discussion with
Target whatever in Target I need you to
speak
okay
this place was on fire it was
okay I'm not going to do that the young
man came over stood behind her I asked
him the same thing
actually no the young lady got in life
and she pushed me too she put her hands
on me as well
I put my hands on no one I came close to
them and they felt threatened
at least hers was a pushback
yeah just to separate you from direct
With Your Inner Space yeah she felt
great cool why did you feel threatened
depends on I don't know what this
discussion is about what were you asking
her to do reach out to her manager so we
have
a discussion about how money works and
how provision works and how it's been
working for a very long
Ivory calls the incident her quote Rosa
Parks moment foreign
I decided to take a stand
this is my Rosa Parks moment dude
don't play with me body camera video
captures Ivory speaking with officers
for more than 30 minutes stressing the
statement she was trying to make we're
having a conversation about how to
reconcile the fact that some people
benefited off of the system
other people
I asked nicely to have that conversation
okay what were you asking for to talk to
for her to connect me with who I could
talk to what was your purpose of that
con that further conversation what were
you going to ask that person for to do
to break the lies around money
what's that mean
we all know money has not been treating
everybody equally okay
I mean money is not the only way for
things to happen
yeah were you asking them to make a
donation essentially or to let you have
them for free what was it I was coming
up to the limit of where I had money
I was trying to ask
if Target would come me
the rest and we would have a
conversation a bigger bubble up a bigger
conversation about why because I know
the heart of this place
okay it's the right place for me to have
this conversation it's like it's a good
company exactly and I was trying to have
a hard conversation in a safe place
I did it the right way and then when I
was I went through the right steps the
reason the problem with my money doesn't
work right is she goes it blocks people
and checkpoints and I'm tired of people
locking good people hours you don't get
paid that you deserve
because choosing to do the right thing
in this world
should cost the Solitaire that's not
fair
the system is people doing the right
thing when Ivory is told she's now
trespassing in Target she becomes
visibly upset
[Music]
will be arrested for this cause
come on no I'm not come on don't make
this uh it's gonna be on camera where
are you holding your lines at come on
Ivory then pushes back arguing she
should not be removed from the store
he gets the right to kick me out after
he hits me he didn't bubble that he
can't blow that up in management yes
really exactly so he can speak on behalf
of the company at that level but he
couldn't do it there
I wasn't out there I'm sure tensions
were a little different than they are at
this moment in time so no you're gonna
reconcile that
you're not going to give me any more
lies you will tell the truth about the
situation no no no no you are trying to
arrest me for him hitting me correct
you are under arrest yes you're under
arrest for menacing and disorderly
conduct
okay now here's what we would like to do
we would rather you walk outside and not
make a big deal
let's have them
don't get resisting too okay let's do it
let's not we're gonna go into it let's
do it you're going to hold every line
you know what you know what happened
here with that officers tell Ivory the
video evidence is against her I know I
just watched the video
I asked to open a conversation and he's
still blocking me out when you guys are
protecting me ma'am you
chase the one employee all the way to
the front Okay you make contact with her
body by pushing your body and hers I
just watched it clear his day on the
video okay he then came out and you
followed him all the way back here okay
making him fear for his safety you
backed him into an office and you got
hit in the face unfortunately when
people got backed into a corner they can
choose no no they can choose to do the
right thing or they can choose to lash
out okay you were in the wrong here just
so I held the line and I no no I I moved
my line continuously I asked and when
they did not respect they were
gatekeeping me like the whole world has
kept people he's free to leave at any
time absolutely but you didn't
absolutely so because it wasn't
qualified the situation
you'll make a stand so they can change
are you ready to go outside if the laws
are meant to hold the whole kid down you
will fight for me my community
responding officers explained the target
manager was not in the wrong and will
not be charged that doesn't just because
your intentions were good does not make
this any less illegal unfortunately
right so what happens when the law are
not okay for people we need to talk
about to enforce the laws that are in
place okay that is our job that is our
goal but he's not getting arrested for
assault
it's not assault he's defending himself
Ivory maintains she did not get physical
with any target employees no there was
not any times that my hands came up to
do anything to anybody
stood my ground okay and when people no
I wasn't standing your ground is not
wrong if you're standing it in the truth
finally Ivory allows officers to
handcuff her
my rights
human being she's then escorted to a
squad car outside the store she
continues to speak with officers saying
she was forcing an important
conversation when it gets to a point
where a young man reached out and hit an
older black woman
regardless of age race anything
you don't hit somebody you don't hit
people but I can also understand why he
did he was he was offending himself
chased him into a closed office
he had no point of
exit
right that was the point I was forcing
him to have a conversation forcing him
to become
when asked if she could have handled the
situation in a different way Ivory
repeats her same stance we haven't been
able to see and communicate with each
other and that's what I was trying to do
and I asked nicely and I got refused and
I stood a line that scared them and they
lashed out so do you think you could
have approached it in a different manner
than how he approached it today and
probably got the same goal the same how
would you how do you expect for I'm
asking for something at the register to
be done the cash register could the
cashier couldn't do it for me I asked
they asked her to Bubble it up to Amanda
that's what you do you take it up the
chain of command
this is the problem my people have been
trying to take it up the chain of
command
and they are getting smacked back down
because the laws are not in their favor
for you to take a hard stand
I I just got hit Ivory was later
convicted of disorderly conduct she was
sentenced to one day in jail and fined
one hundred and ten dollars reporting
for long crime Network I'm Sierra
Gillespie